backwater home 2x IMC pilot Barker this  hidden bootlegging colony is defined by  its elevation changes bearing heights of  terrain and open fields give Titans room  to battle it out while pilots can travel  underground through grain storage  facilities or use the elevated railways  to gain the advantage  known to the militia only is sown 18 the  IMC advanced robotics facility is a  fast-paced environment divided by a  central supply path many pilots will  seek the protection of the facility's  interior passages while others will take  advantage of the long sightlines  provided by the limited rooftop cover  sand trap deep reservoirs of unrefined  fuel have transformed this  recommissioned imc facility into a key  strategic point on the frontier its vast  open spaces favored titan movement while  pilots can escape into the deep chasms  where skilled wall running is essential  to avoid the fatal drop into the fuel  reservoirs  you